il arrive dans des camions poussiéreux
sous le choc ils fuient la dernière
enclave de l'état islamique
ici dans les plaines de l'est de la
syrie soupçonnée d'être membre du groupe
djihadiste ils sont interrogés par les
forces de coalition
parmi eux se trouve une jeune femme
originaire de toronto
je ne savais rien de l'état islamique
dit elle cet étudiant de 28 ans est
venue avec ses enfants à la demande de
son mari
tout comme sept autres canadiennes 34
ans de l'alberta il m'a dit tu dois
venir ici c'est obligatoire raconte elle
une femme musulmane doit obéir je n'ai
pas le choix elles restent détenus en
syrie
tout comme au moins une dizaine d'autres
canadiens et des centaines d'occidentaux
du retrait de ses troupes
les etats-unis ont demandé cette semaine
à leurs alliés de rapatrier leurs
ressortissants détenus en syrie
ce que le canada refuse de faire pour
l'instant le match où tout un casse-tête
pour les pays alliés des américains mais
des experts appellent à la prudence
ce qu'ils avaient fait je dirais le
comique comme il l'appelle le djihad ici
ou là aux quatre coins du monde n'ont
jamais renoncé
non jamais renoncer à leur à leurs
engagements
le défi pour les pays c'est que ils
n'ont pas forcément la preuve que ces
gens là ont participé à des activités
terroristes donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
une fois que ces gens-là rentrer au pays
le débat a fait rage en occident alors
que l'état islamique ne contrôlent plus
qu'un territoire d'une cinquantaine de
kilomètres carrés à la frontière entre
l'irak et la syrie
ici sébastien desrosiers radio canada
montréal